Cells form the basic units of life!
We know this!
And by now we even know how the discovery
of cells, as seen in the tree cork, was a
breakthrough in biological studies!
Now it’s time we have a look at how the
cells actually look under a microscope!
For this we select onion peel as our specimen.
But before we begin with the procedure, let
us first collect the necessary requirements.
We will need a microscope, a slide, cover
slip, iodine solution, water and forceps.
Anything else we are left with?
Well, the most important of all is the specimen!
That is an onion peel.
Now that we are all set with the equipments
needed, let us begin with the amazing experiment
of observing the onion cells under the microscope!
Firstly, we take the onion peel and with the
help of the forceps pull away the thin lining
from the inner surface.
Before placing this on the slide, we first
add a drop of water on then place the onion
peel on it.
We are NOT supposed to touch the peel and
even the slide with our fingers.
Next, we add two drops of dilute iodine solution.
Hold on…Do you know why is iodine solution
added to this specimen?
We do this so that we can clearly
see all the PARTS of the cell.
Else it is difficult to study them as they are transparent…
It would even be difficult to differentiate
between the various parts.
Now we place a cover slip in this manner and
make sure that no air bubbles are formed on
the slide.
With this our slide is ready!
This entire process of setting up the microscope
along with the slide is termed ‘MOUNTING’.
It is also important to see that there is
enough light falling on the mirror of the
microscope.
Shall we observe it now?
Here we go…
Wow!
Doesn’t it look amazing?
Now before studying these, tell me one thing!
Do plant and animal cells look the same?
Do they have the same organelles?
Or are the two types different in some ways?
Well, plant and animal cells are slightly different.
When cells from a human cheek are scraped
with a sterile cotton bud and mounted, similar
but not exactly same cells are seen under
the microscope!
Roughly, we have these thick, distinct borders
that differentiate each cell form the other
one!
Then we have these tiny dark spots scattered all over!
Also, we can spot this prominent, circular
structure here which is very darkly stained.
Any idea what these things are?
Well, these are the cell constituents.
Let us get introduced to each in the next video!